[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos de cómo las personas con
ansiedad enfrentan la reapertura de
lugares públicos en el marco de la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 para ello nos
acompaña cristina mesa viera psicóloga y
doctora en salud pública de la
universidad de berna doctora gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 en
la salud y comencemos por despejar y
aclarar qué es la ansiedad que sucede en
el orden de los pensamientos en una
persona con ansiedad
bueno lo primero que tenemos que tener
en cuenta es que la ansiedad la tenemos
todos todas las personas sentimos
ansiedad y eso no quiere decir que
tengamos un trastorno psiquiátrico o
psicológico la ansiedad sirve para
y adelantarnos a situaciones que pueden
ser riesgosas y por lo tanto tomar
acciones para hacerlo en el caso de
coronavirus sentir ansiedad el
coronavirus nos puede evitar situaciones
de contagio sin embargo la entidad puede
volverse problemática cuando la
respuesta es mucho mayor al estímulo o
cuando nos dificulta seguir con nuestra
vida normal
ahora doctora en esta nueva etapa muchas
personas se enfrentan escenarios muy
diferentes al aislamiento y ya se puede
viajar tener reuniones ir a bares entre
otras muchas actividades sin embargo la
pandemia sigue existiendo y el final no
se vislumbra cómo pueden afectar estos
nuevos escenarios a las personas con
ansiedad
si una de las características de la
ansiedad en la anticipación constante y
el pensamiento de las cosas de que las
cosas no van a salir como las planeamos
entonces a pesar de que hay mucha
reapertura las normas siguen cambiando
con una frecuencia relativamente rápida
para eso se recomienda hacer planes a
corto plazo de tal manera que podamos de
actividades y retomar aquellas cosas que
no hacíamos anteriormente pero que las
podamos realizar y no frustrarnos cuando
éstas sean
tengan que posponerse debido al cambio
de las normas entonces si queremos salir
de vacaciones no esperar a hacerlo uno o
dos meses sino hacerlo el fin de semana
si queremos vernos con amigos no dañarlo
con mucho tiempo de anticipación sino
llamar y decirle vamos a tomar un café
hoy yo vamos a hacer la caminada corta
hoy de tal manera que podamos controlar
un poco más ese tiempo y no quedarnos
pensando en todo aquello que pueda salir
mal doctora le pregunto qué síntomas
puede experimentar a alguien que tiene
una ansiedad significativa y que debe
afrontar ahora en momentos de
interacción social y salida mientras la
pandemia continúa exacto la ansiedad se
caracteriza por unos síntomas
fisiológicos como sudoración
palpitaciones a veces si es
el sentimiento de ahogo también tiene
hay veces insomnio y problemas para
conciliar el sueño entonces digamos las
personas que quieren volver al trabajo
puede que tengan problemas en la
conciliación del sueño por ejemplo por
las preocupaciones ya no van a ser sólo
desde el punto de vista laboral sino
también en cómo va a ser el ambiente en
el que voy a estar trabajando nuevamente
hay personas que tienen también ansiedad
social y estaban más tranquilos en su
casa entonces ahora tienen que
enfrentarse nuevamente a situaciones
sociales entonces la ansiedad tiene
muchas formas de de manifestarse y eso
afecta a las personas de forma distinta
también doctora y no sólo los adultos le
pregunto cómo gestionar esta situación
con los niños ansiosos se ven afectados
de una manera particular ellos si los
niños han sido gran y grandes afectados
de la pandemia pues recordemos que el
asistir al colegio y relacionarse con
los niños no es sólo para el desarrollo
cognitivo sino que tiene un componente
de desarrollo emocional importante
entonces el no asistir al colegio
retrasa
y digamos que no permite que se
desarrollen muy bien en esa área
entonces a los niños es muy importante
explicarles paso a paso de cómo hacer el
regreso por ejemplo a la escuela si va a
hacer en alternancia si van a volver del
todo cómo se puede esperar que sea el
aula de clase y van a tener que usar
tapabocas o no te van a poder jugar
igual que sus compañeros o no es muy
importante mantener sus rutinas ya sea
en casa o en el colegio que las comidas
se harán a la misma hora que los tiempos
de juego sean a la misma hora de tal
manera que ellos puedan predecir qué va
a pasar pero por 'la proporcionales de
espacios seguros para actividad libre
deportiva y de recreación entonces hacer
citas con personas allegadas a otros
niños digamos al aire libre
permitir que expresen sus miedos porque
las preocupaciones que tenemos como
adultos no son las mismas preocupaciones
que los niños así es doctora gracias por
su tiempo y por estar aquí con nosotros
en 5 minutos con de france 24 ustedes
también gracias continúa con nosotros
porque hay mucho más para ver
[Música]